bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de nietzsche on avait déjà parlé de
nietzsche dans une précédente vidéo
mais aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser plus
particulièrement à sa conception de la
morale donc nietzsche c'est un
philosophe allemand du 19e siècle
il a exercé une grande influence sur sa
postérité et en même temps c'est un
penseur à contre-courant c'est un
penseur qui rejette l'héritage de la
plupart des philosophes considérés comme
des références à commencer par socrate
et il y avait hier que schopenhauer qui
trouve grâce aux yeux de nietzsche
c'est le seul penseur au khalife est
dédié l'un de ses livres
bien qu'il s'en soit écartée par la
suite et en même temps ça s'explique par
le fait que schopenhauer comme nietzsche
ont tous les deux développer une
approche naturaliste de la pensée c'est
à dire que pour l'un comme pour l'autre
les idées étaient d'abord des
productions du corps ce qui veut dire
que pour comprendre une idée pour
comprendre son essence il faut
comprendre le corps dont elle émane
il faut comprendre son origine
physiologique et ça ça va nous permettre
de mettre en lumière la conception de la
morale de nietzsche parce que la morale
n'échappe pas à cette règle et
comprendre la morale pour nietzsche
c'est comprendre qui a inventé la morale
c'est comprendre l'origine physiologique
de la morale et c'est ce dont on va
parler dans cette vidéo alors la
conception morale de nietzsche
elle est exposée dans son livre la
généalogie de la morale qui fait suite à
son autre livre par delà le bien et le
mal est donc comme je le disais pour
nietzsche il est essentiel d'expliquer
d'où vient la morale pour comprendre ce
qu'est la morale ce qu'elle est dans son
essence
il ya donc une dimension historique dans
la philosophie de nietzsche puisque pour
lui toute idée toute valeur est d'abord
le fruit d'une histoire une histoire qui
a un commencement qui a une naissance et
la naissance de la morale c'est la
religion
nietzsche est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
critiques envers la religion
il est critique de manière générale
envers toutes les philosophies qui
présuppose un arrière monde
alors qu'est ce que c'est
arrières monde bien c'est l'idée qu'il
existerait un monde
au delà de notre monde physique et
matérielle s'est vidée par exemple qu'il
existerait un monde intelligible comme
on le trouve chez platon ou qu'il
existerait un paradis comme on le trouve
chez les chrétiens d'ailleurs pour
nietzsche platon et christianisme même
combat même combat parce qu'on a affaire
à deux conceptions du monde dualiste
c'est à dire des conceptions du monde
qui présuppose une séparation entre un
ici bas le monde matériel et un au delà
le monde spirituel le monde divin ce
dualisme nietzsche le rejette
parce qu'il considère que cela témoigne
d'un rejet de notre monde
vouloir qu'il existe un monde au delà
d'une autre c'est d'une certaine manière
ne pas accueillir notre monde ne pas
s'en satisfaire
c'est avoir besoin d'un monde dans
lequel les difficultés que nous
rencontrons ici bas n'existeront plus et
donc ça pour nietzsche ça dénote une
inadaptation à notre monde
ça dénote que nietzsche appellent leurs
sentiments
pour nietzsche toutes les philosophies
du dualisme sont des philosophies du
ressentiment
autrement dit ce sont des philosophies
qui condamne notre monde qui condamne le
monde la matière et même au delà qui
condamne la vie elle-même leurs
sentiments c'est vouloir que la vie ne
soit pas la vie c'est vouloir que la vie
ne soit pas le terrain d'affrontement
des forces parce que c'est d'abord ça la
vie ces terrains d'affrontement de
forces qui s'opposent qui se télescopent
c'est ça la vie c'est un rapport de
force rapport de force permanent et dans
ce rapport de force il y en a qui sont
plus ou moins dotées qui sont plus ou
moins privilégiés par la nature
évidemment les moins privilégiés vont
être ceux qui vont le plus rejeté ce
principe de l'affrontement des forces et
qui sont ceux qui vont rejeter ce
principe est bien pour nietzsche c'est
très clair ce sont les faibles alors on
pourrait dire d'accord les faibles
rejette le monde physique parce qu'il
est le lieu d'affrontements des forces
effectivement quand on est faible on a
plutôt intérêt à éviter le conflit
on a plutôt intérêt à éviter de ce conte
front tu es à des forces supérieures à
la nôtre il en va de notre survie et
vous allez me dire quel rapport avec la
morale mais vous allez voir que c'est
très simple pour nietzsche l'invention
de la morale correspond d'abord à une
stratégie des faibles pour se protéger
des forts alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que la morale elle est
fondée sur un ensemble d'interdits la
morale c'est ce qui nous dit tu dois est
tu ne dois pas tu peux où tu ne peux pas
donc ce qui définit la morale c'est la
restriction ce qui définit la morale
c'est la limite à notre comportement
la morale nous dit tu ne peux pas faire
tout ce que tu veux tu es obligé de
prendre en compte l'autre
et parce que l'autre existe tu ne peux
pas faire tout ce que tu veux tu ne peux
pas vivre comme si l'autre n'existait
pas ce qui veut dire que ce qui fonde la
morale c'est l'existence d'autrui et
c'est vrai que si vous vivez tout seul
dans la forêt d'une certaine manière la
morale ne vous servira à rien elle nous
servira à rien parce que vous n'aurez
pas besoin d'un code de conduite
le code de conduite vous en avez besoin
quand vous êtes en rapport avec l'autre
pas quand vous êtes tout seul pas quand
votre objectif c'est la survie donc ce
qui fonde la morale c'est l'existence de
l'autre c'est la prise en compte de
l'autre et donc la morale nous dit que
parce que l'autre existe on doit le
respecter
on doit respecter sa dignité on doit
respecter la valeur de sa vie on ne peut
pas utiliser l'autre comme un moyen pour
parvenir à nos fins c'est ce qu'on
retrouve dans la morale quand sienne
l'idée que l'autre ne peut jamais être
traité comme un moyen mais doit toujours
être traité comme une fin en soi je ne
peux pas utiliser l'autre comme un moyen
parce que l'autre est un autre moi même
parce qu'il possède une conscience parce
que sa valeur est au delà de toute
marchandisation
au delà de toute instrumentalisation et
parce que l'autre est un autre moi même
je ne peux pas lui infliger je ne peux
pas lui faire subir ce que je ne
voudrais pas qu'on fasse subir
je suis donc obligé d'en rabattre sur
mes instincts sur mon animalité pour
laisser une place à l'autre pour le
laisser exister à mes côtés donc ça
c'est ce qui fonde la morale et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fonde également toute
vie sociale
il faut bien comprendre que la morale la
religion
ce sont également des systèmes de
coexistence sociale
c'est ce qui permet aux individus de
cohabiter les uns à côté des autres de
manière pacifique
s'il n'y avait pas de morale il n'y
aurait pas de coexistence pacifique
entre les individus
autrement dit toute vie en société
serait impossible et c'est parce qu'il
est nécessaire de fixer des limites à
notre conduite que nous avons inventé
les notions de bien et de mal le bien et
le mal
ce sont d'abord des créations humaines
dont le but est de s'accorder sur ce que
l'on a le droit de faire et sur ce que
l'on a pas le droit de faire donc la
morale si on voulait la définir de
manière extrêmement simple voire
simpliste c'est la valorisation du bien
et la dévalorisation du mal et quand je
dis dévalorisation on peut même aller
jusqu'à dire condamnation la morale
condamne le mal est dans cette idée de
condamnation il ya un peu plus que
l'idée du simple rejet il y à l'idée de
la culpabilisation faire le mal doit
nous faire ou sentir coupable ce qu'on
appelle la mauvaise conscience
saissac cherche à me dire la morale en
faisant le mal
on doit se sentir coupable et c'est
exactement là que réside le problème
selon nietzsche
le problème ne réside pas tant dans le
fait d'ériger des règles de conduite y
parce qu'après tout sans règles de
conduite on ne pourrait pas coexister
mais le véritable problème c'est
l'entreprise de culpabilisation qui
accompagne la morale est d'ailleurs
cette culpabilisation on la voit à
l'oeuvre dans le champ lexical de la
morale et de la religion dans la
religion chrétienne on trouve très
fréquemment la notion de péché de pêcher
et ans qui est censé nous conduire en
enfer et les sept péchés capitaux sont
là pour nous rappeler que
si on se laisse aller aux vices on sera
tôt ou tard juger par le tout puissant
cette idée de jugement de jugement
dernier
elle aussi va dans le sens de cette
culpabilité et le jugement de celui qui
a fait le mal c'est le châtiment
autrement dit pour nietzsche les sens de
la morale c'est la culpabilité et
pourquoi la culpabilité et quelque chose
d'indispensable et bien nietzsche à la
réponse c'est parce que la culpabilité
est le seul moyen d'empêcher le fort
d'exprimer sa force
la culpabilité est fait pour empêcher le
fort d'être fort pour l'empêché
d'exprimer sa nature d'être fort alors
vous allez me dire on peut être fort
sans chercher à nuire aux faibles sans
chercher à faire subir aux faibles le
poids de notre force et c'est vrai mais
sauf que on l'a dit tout à l'heure
la vie c'est d'abord le théâtre du
conflit
terrain d'affrontement des forces et
donc objectivement dans cette situation
le faible est pénalisé si l'être humain
est d'abord un être des pulsions un être
de vitalité un hêtre instinctif qui va
tout faire pour la survie il est évident
que dans ce jeu
l'espérance de vie du faible et réduites
lorsqu'il y as affrontements pour la
ressource
lorsqu'il y accomplit pour
l'appropriation du point d'eau le faible
il est un peu à la remorque faible c'est
pas celui qui va nous faire triompher
c'est plutôt celui qu'on va envoyer en
éclaireur et qui risquent d'y passer
on va pas se mentir donc dans une vie
terrestre qui se définit d'abord comme
le lieu d'affrontements des forces
le faible part avec un handicap on a
beau aujourd'hui vouloir nier cette
nature animal et instinctif de l'être
humain
il n'empêche que la force que ce soit la
force physique ou la force psychologique
reste aujourd'hui un avantage évolutif
quand bien même les avancées
technologiques viendrait largement
relativisé cette valeur de la force
pour en revenir à la notion de
culpabilité ce que nous dit nietzsche
c'est que l'idée même de culpabilité
n'aurait pas pu naître
dans l'esprit d'un fort parce que le
fort ils s'en moquent de la culpabilité
il s'en moque que son adversaire
n'éprouve pas de culpabilité parce que
c'est pas son problème
deux forts qui s'affrontent ne vont pas
se reprocher d'utiliser la force d'un
contre l'autre deux forts qui
s'affrontent ne vont pas aller porter
plainte
ils vont mesurer leur force l'un à
l'autre et c'est le plus fort qui
triomphera et le vaincu acceptera sa
défaite au nom du fait qu'il avait
accepté cette règle du jeu on voit mal
leonidas guider son armée jusqu aux
thermopyles et se plaindre d'avoir été
tués par les perses
on voit mal l'aristocrate provoquer en
duel celui qui l'aura insulté pour
ensuite se plaindre d'avoir reçu une
balle
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas parce
que le fort accepte l'idée que dans la
vie il est parfois nécessaire de se
confronter à la force de l'autre et la
même façon que la gazelle ne portera
jamais plainte contre le lion pour la
voir manger pour nietzsche il n'y a
aucune raison que l'on fasse
culpabiliser le fort pour avoir employé
sa force c'est à dire pour avoir
simplement exprimé sa nature
alors évidemment la vision nietzschéenne
c'est une vision naturaliste des
rapports humains
autrement dit pour nietzsche l'homme est
d'abord un animal l'animal
c'est ce qui est animée et animée ça
veut dire doté d'une âme à nîmes au sens
latin
c'est le principe vital ce qui définit
l'être humain comme tous les animaux
c'est son élan vital c'est son souffle
de vie et de leurs qu'on a défini la vie
comme un lieu de conflits comme un lieu
d'affrontement des forces
il n'y a aucune raison parce qu'il n'y a
aucune possibilité d'aller à l'encontre
de ce principe la vitalité et le
principe de tout être vivant dont dans
cette situation où le faible est
pénalisée par rapport au fort
il est évident que le faible a tout
intérêt à priver le fort de son arme
fatale le fait blacks ont intérêt à ce
que le forts n'exercent pas sa force
contre lui et donc est ce que va faire
le faible il va inventer la morale
il va inventer des règles il va inventer
des valeurs il va inventer des interdits
qui font que le fort va hésiter à
employer sa force que le fort ne sera
plus légitime à exercer sa force et
c'est ça pour nietzsche l'acte de
naissance de la morale la morale c'est
une entreprise de culpabilisation du
fort inventé par les faibles pour se
réapproprier le pouvoir si vous préférez
pour nietzsche le faible est conscient
qu'il ne peut pas employer sa force
contre le fort le feb est conscient que
dans cette équation il est perdant donc
le faible est obligé de recourir à la
ruse à la stratégie il est obligé de
trouver une voie détournée pour
renverser le rapport de domination
si on l'en ferme cela seul dans une
pièce avec un fort le faible est
conscient qu'il est mort mais si on
l'enferment dans une salle de procès
dans une salle de procès dans laquelle
on fait appliquer la loi la loi qui dit
qu'on doit pas faire du mal aux faibles
qu'on ne doit pas le faire souffrir et
bien dans cette situation là le fort
devient le faible celui qui a exercé sa
force devient le coupable coupable non
plus aux yeux de la nature et du
principe de l'élan vital mais coupable
aux yeux des règles morales pablo aux
yeux des règles de la coexistence
pacifique
oh pas bhl aux yeux de la société voilà
ce qui définit le principe de la morale
selon nietzsche le principe de la morale
c'est l'auto institutions de la bonté
des bons et qui sont les bons ce sont
les faibles qui sont les bons ce sont
ceux qui ne peuvent pas se permettre
d'être autre chose que bon parce que
pour nietzsche si on est bon c'est
d'abord parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
d'être autre chose ou si on est bon
c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas s'attirer
les foudres du fort et donc en érigeant
leur bonté en valeur les faibles venait
de créer la morale donc évidemment je me
doute que parmi vous que mon ne sera pas
d'accord avec cette vision et je n'ai
pas besoin de préciser que ce n'est pas
l'objet l'objet n'est pas de vous faire
adhérer à la morale
n l'idée de vous faire entendre un point
de vue différent sur les origines d'une
morale qu'on a tendance à considérer
comme un phénomène spontané comme
quelque chose qui serait inhérent à la
nature de l'homme
peut-être que la morale et quelque chose
d'inhérent à la nature de l'homme
mais peut-être que c'est aussi le fruit
d'un constat le constat de
l'impossibilité de survivre si on limite
pas l'expression de la force
qu'est ce qui définit en règle générale
les règles morales c'est la
bienveillance c'est la générosité c'est
la considération de son prochain
c'est ça qu'on retrouve dans la plupart
des systèmes moreau la considération de
son prochain
mais ça pour nietzsche c'est quelque
chose qui n'a pas sa place dans la
nature reprendre l'exemple que danic
l'oiseau 3 ne se pose pas la question de
la moralité de son action lorsqu'il
mange un agneau l'oiseau de proie ne
considère pas l'agneau comme son ennemi
au contraire droit en raffolent de
l'agneau alors que l'agneau parce qu'il
a développé une peur de l'oiseau de
proie il va le détester il va lui en
vouloir il va lui reprocher d'être un
oiseau de proie
il va le lui reprocher parce que
l'oiseau 3 est une menace pour lui et ça
ça permet de comprendre ce que nietzsche
considère comme étant l'origine de nos
jugements moraux et de comprendre que le
bien et le mal ne sont pas des notions
transcendante et absolue c'est à dire ne
sont pas des notions qui nous viennent
du ciel mais ce sont des notions
proprement humaine qui n'ont d'autre but
que de nous protéger
l'idée que le bien et le mal serait des
notions universelles voir divine on each
ça n'a aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens
parce qu'en tant que naturaliste il veut
trouver l'explication naturel l'
explication physiologique de toutes nos
productions mental de toutes nos
productions culturelles
le bien et le mal c'est ce que l'on
considère comme étant bien où est en mal
du point de vue de notre intérêt c'est
ça qu'il faut comprendre le bien et le
mal répond d'abord à une logique
d'intérêt ce qui veut dire que si on est
engagé dans une lutte contre le fort on
n'a aucun intérêt à placer cette lutte
sur son propre terrain on n'a aucun
intérêt à rivaliser de force avec lui au
contraire on a tout intérêt à montrer
que son terrain n'est pas légitime
on a intérêt à montrer qu'en recourant à
la force
lefort fait quelque chose d'injuste fait
quelque chose de condamnable de
répréhensible et si on arrive à faire
admettre l'idée qu'en utilisant la force
le fort se rend coupable eh bien on a
gagné on a gagné parce qu'on aura
entraîné la réprobation vis-à-vis du
fort qui dès lors cesse d'être fort le
fort isolé cesse d'être fort le fort
face à la foule de faibles il est
dépassé
c'est en ce sens qu'on peut définir la
morale comme la force des faibles parce
que c'est la force des faibles coalisés
qui parce qu'ils ne sont pas dotés d'une
force à titre individuel vont chercher à
créer la force à titre collectif
donc évidemment si les faibles
constituent la majorité d'une population
et qu'ils arrivent à s'entendre sur ce
qu'ils veulent condamner chez le fort
qu'à ce moment là ils deviennent
l'effort deviennent les dominants la
morale pour nietzsche c'est une
véritable entreprise de renversement des
valeurs renversement des valeurs qui va
consister à faire passer la force pour
une faiblesse et la faiblesse pour une
force et d'ailleurs on voit très bien
avec l'exemple du christ que nietzsche
critique de manière extrêmement
virulente la passion du christ la
crucifixion du christ c'est la
sanctification de la faiblesse
c'est la béatification de l'impuissance
c'est comme ça que nietzsche analyse le
christianisme la béatification de
l'impuissance l'éloge de la passivité
parce que le christ c'est celui qui
accepte son sort il accepte sa
condamnation et lorsqu'il dit
pardonne-leur car ils ne savent pas ce
qu'ils font
il est en train de trouver des excuses à
ses oppresseurs il est en train d'aimer
ce qui met fin à son élan vital pour
nietzsche la morale est quelque chose de
mortifère mortifère parce qu'elle va
contre la pulsion vitale de l'homme
cette pulsion vitale qui va faire qu'on
va se défendre coûte que coûte face à un
ennemi c'est à dire face à quiconque
représente une menace contre notre
survie accepter que l'autre menace notre
vie accepter qu'il interrompe notre élan
vital selon nietzsche
c'est ça qui devrait être condamné c'est
ça qui devrait faire l'objet d'une
disqualification et au contraire exalté
l'élan vital célébrer la volonté de
puissance
c'est ça qui devrait être érigée en
valeur suprême voilà pourquoi la
critique nietzschéenne de la morale ne
correspond pas à une absence de morale
c'est simplement que pour nietzsche
parler de bien et de mal c'est hypocrite
cette hypocrite parce que c'est vouloir
faire passer pour des principes absolus
ce qui ne sont en fait que des moyens de
survie c'est vouloir faire passer pour
des valeurs universelles et
transcendante
ce qui ne sont en fait que des
inventions du genre humain pour se
conserver
voilà pourquoi nietzsche récuse le terme
de bien et de mal mais il ne récuse pas
pour autant l'idée de bons et de mauvais
parce que bon et mauvais c'est au jour
par rapport à quelque chose
rien n'est ni bon ni mauvais en soi
c'est toujours bon ou mauvais d'un
certain point de vue est ce qu'un
couteau c'est bon ou mauvais si c'est
pour couper une entrecôte c'est bon et
si c'est pour aller planter le voisin
bas c'est mauvais si tant est qu on
admettre que planter son voisin c'est
quelque chose de mauvais et voyez c'est
toujours relatif
ça dépend toujours du système de normes
et de critères compris suppose donc a
pas de bien et de mal absolu
il n'y a pas de bien et de mal en soi le
bien et le mal sont relatifs
relatifs à la survie de l'être humain
relatifs à l'intérêt des hommes et
toutes les valeurs que l'homme va créer
pour disqualifier tel comportement pour
juger que telle chose est bonne et elle
chose est mauvaise pour nietzsche tout
ça n'est qu'artifice tout ça n'est
qu'hypocrisie tout ça n'est que vaine
tentative pour se cacher à nous mêmes
notre véritable nature et donc à chaque
fois qu'on condamne le comportement d'un
être humain à partir de critères qui
seraient le bien et le mal
on est dans la négation de l'essence
même de l'être humain
on est dans la négation de la vitalité
qui animent l'être humain on est dans ce
que nietzsche appelle le nihilisme alors
si vous n'êtes pas familier de la
philosophie de nietzsche et que vous
allez rechercher la définition du mot
nihilisme dans un dictionnaire vous
allez voir que la définition qui vous
est donné c'est le rejet de toutes les
valeurs
le rejet de toutes les croyances de
toutes les normes qui fonde une société
et là vous allez vous dire c'est
nietzsche qui élit liste puisque c'est
nietzsche qui refuse d'accorder de la
valeur aux noces au moral
c'est nietzsche qui refuse d'accepter la
distinction entre le bien et le mal
oui mais sauf que pour nietzsche le
nihilisme
ce n'est pas le rejet des valeurs
dominantes
ce n'est pas le rejet des valeurs qui
ont triomphé
c'est le rejet de ce qui fait l'essence
de l'homme c'est le rejet de ce que
nietzsche considère comme étant la
véritable valeur de l'homme est la
véritable valeur de l'homme selon
nietzsche
c'est la puissance tout ce qu'ils
rejettent la puissance participe du
nihilisme tout ce qu'ils rejettent la
vitalité tout ce qu'ils rejettent la
force tout ce qu'ils rejettent
l'affirmation de soi pour nietzsche
c'est du nihilisme le nihilisme ne
consiste non pas à dire que rien n'a de
valeur que toutes les valeurs se valent
le nihilisme consiste à refuser le fait
que ce qui a de la valeur
c'est la puissance c'est ça le nihilisme
pour
c'est rejeter cette valeur fondamentale
de l'être humain qui est la volonté de
puissance pour need il n'y a pas de bien
et de mal mais il ya du bon et du
mauvais et le bon et le mauvais
permettent de remettre en perspective la
valeur des normes et des concepts humain
donc il peut y avoir morale du fort la
morale de la bravoure la morale du
panache et même d'une certaine manière
la morale du sacrifice parce que pour
nietzsche ce n'est pas la forme de
l'acte qui fait sa valeur ce qui fait la
valeur morale d'un acte c'est sa force
autrement dit c'est la volonté de
puissance qui investit cet acte on peut
trouver de la volonté de puissance dans
un acte de générosité
on peut trouver la volonté de puissance
dans un acte de partage ou de
bienveillance c'est pas incompatibles
ce n'est pas incompatible parce que tout
dépend de l'énergie consommée dans notre
action est ce que nietzsche appelle la
morale d'esclaves
c'est lorsque l'action et réaliser non
pas à partir d'une volonté de puissance
animé par l'élan vital animé par
l'exaltation de la vie
c'est lorsque l'action est animé par le
ressentiment
c'est lorsque l'action est animé par
l'animosité par la jalousie parlant vie
c'est-à-dire par des forces qui sont
anti vitale par des forces mortifère
le combat n'est pas mortifère parce que
le combat fait partie de la vie à ce
combat est même l'un des principes de la
vie
mais le ressentiment le désir de
vengeance l'aigreur la rancune
ça ce sont des forces mortifère ce sont
les forces du faible du fait qu a besoin
de recourir à la stratégie pour parvenir
à ses fins l'hypocrisie c'est la force
du faible la médisance c'est la force du
faible et ce sont des forces mortifère
parce qu'elles vont à l'encontre du
principe de la vie qui est l'affirmation
la volonté de puissance c'est une
volonté d'affirmation là où le faible va
s'inscrire non pas dans une logique
d'affirmation mais dans une logique de
négation le faible ce n'est pas celui
qui va chercher à affirmer ce qui les
met à
et ce quel autre c'est ça la différence
le faible c'est celui qui a besoin de
nier l'autre pour pouvoir s'affirmer
autrement dit c'est celui qui est
toujours dans un rapport de comparaison
avec l'autre de frustration vis-à-vis de
l'autre c'est celui qui voyant que son
voisin à une plus belle voiture une
belle maison plus belle femme va nourrir
une rancoeur contre lui va employer sa
vie à lui nuire
simplement parce qu'il est jaloux de ce
que lui n'a pas simplement par faiblesse
morale la morale du ressentiment la
morale d'esclaves
c'est la morale de la négation c'est la
morale de la réactivité vis-à-vis de
l'autre là où le fort va être dans un
rapport pro actif au monde c'est à dire
le désir d'entreprendre le désir de
produire le désir de créer le fait
d'être dans un rapport de réaction
vis-à-vis du monde faible c'est celui
qui a besoin du fort pour pouvoir
employer contre le fort les armes du
faible si vous préférez le faible c'est
celui qui a besoin du fort pour jouer
son rôle de faibles là où le fort n'a
pas du tout besoin du faible pour jouer
son rôle de fort l eufor ne jouent pas
de rôle ils se contentent d'être il se
contente d'affirmer sa puissance vitale
il se contente d'affirmer sa volonté de
puissance se contente d'être dans la vie
et encore une fois c'est très important
de comprendre qu'il y à mille et une
façons d'être dans l'affirmation ya
mille et une façons d'être dans la
volonté de puissance et tous ceux qui
vous diront que la volonté de puissance
c'est le fait de montrer à l'autre notre
puissance c'est le fait de l'écraser de
notre puissance
tous ceux là n'ont rien compris à ce que
dit nietzsche
tout cela sont même exactement dans ce
que nietzsche méprise à savoir dans
leurs sentiments à savoir dans le besoin
de justifier ce qu'ils sont le besoin de
prouver des choses à prouver des choses
aux autres nous prouver des choses elle
même parce que quand on a besoin de
prouver des choses c'est qu'on a besoin
de prouver des choses c'est parce qu'on
manque de la confiance en ce que l'on
n'ait on a besoin de prouver des choses
quand on manque de confiance quand on
manque d'assurance
quand on a besoin de se rassurer mais le
fort n'a pas besoin de se rassurer
l'eufor est conscient de sa force et
c'est parce qu'il est conscient et
confiant en sa force qui n'a pas besoin
de la fiche en permanence qui n'a pas
besoin d'en faire la démonstration
permanente l'exemple donnent souvent
c'est le boxeur de compétition où le
combattant de mma qui est généralement
un individu extrêmement paisible en
dehors du ring
les boxeurs les combattants dans leur
grande majorité ne sont pas des gens qui
vont chercher l'embrouillé n'ont pas
besoin de prouver qu'ils sont les
meilleurs
il se contente de l'être ça fait manière
la volonté de montrer qu'on est le
meilleur est inversement proportionnelle
à la certitude que l'on a d'être le
meilleur
encore une fois vouloir prouver quelque
chose
c'est considérer qu on peut en douter et
quand on dit quelque chose on en cherche
pas la preuve le surhomme n'a rien à
prouver et c'est justement ça qui en
fait un surhomme il n'a rien à prouver
être dans la réactivité vis-à-vis de
l'autre être dans la nécessité de se
positionner comme supérieur à l'autre ce
n'est pas être un surhomme n'est pas
être dans l'affirmation c'est encore
être dans le nihilisme être dans
l'affirmation c'est ne pas accorder de
valeur c'est ne pas accorder
d'importance au jugement de l'autre
c'est ça être un surhomme ne pas
accorder d'importance au jugement de
l'autre le fort n'est pas dans la
réaction vis-à-vis du faible c'est le
faible qui est dans la réaction
vis-à-vis du fort le fort n'est pas dans
la réaction
le fort et dans l'indifférence
le fort n'est pas quelqu'un qui va sur
réagir aux actes du faible et s'il
réagit c'est parce qu'il aura considéré
que le faible pouvait représenter à un
moment donné une menace contre lui ou
une tentative de lui opposer sa force
et dans ce cas là le fort fera ce qu'il
sait faire de mieux
il emploiera sa force mais ne
l'emploiera que parce qu'il aura estimé
que ne pas l'employer
ce serait comme nier la vie en lui le
fort chez nietzsche
c'est d'abord un combattant de la vie
d'une vie qui ne rejette pas le conflit
vie qui assume le conflit d'une vie
consciente de ne pas être que paix amour
d'une vie consciente du fait que la
destruction fait parfois partie de la
vie il faut parfois savoir détruire pour
reconstruire le fort n'hésite pas à
détruire parce qu'il sait qu'il
reconstruit rang et que de là même
façon que la naissance succède à la mort
la construction succède à la destruction
le fort ne se plaint pas que la vie de
face aux friands parce qu'il sait que la
souffrance n'est qu'éphémère et surtout
il sait que vouloir que la vie le
prémunissent contre la souffrance
ce serait vouloir que la vie ne soit pas
la vie ce serait vouloir que la vie ne
soit plus la vie lefort accepte la vie
il embrasse la vie danse avec la vie
parce qu'ils aiment l'idée que ceux qui
le traversent
soit en même temps ce qui le dépasse que
ceux qui l'animent soit aussi ceux qui
lui survivra lefort accepte la vie et le
fort accepte le faible même s'il
aimerait parfois que le faible se
réveille que le faible se redresse que
le faible vive car alors le faible ne
sera plus le faible
il deviendra m il deviendra un surhomme
je vous remercie
[Musique]